[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Pierre Pernaut
bonsoir bonsoir ici ce soir pour
répondre à la question qui me est-ce que
vous auriez un bon fabricant de sabots
Amboise oui ça revient
la banque Lazard France et ami de
François Hollande c'est donc un bon pied
de gauche voilà et si on gagne c'est lui
qui lui prêtera son yacht
toujours en paix de nous on est l'un des
meilleurs artisans du rap français
complet à Jean-Pierre il fait du rap à
l'ancienne
mais je commence à évaluer
notre invité du samedi 20h ce soir
[Musique]
voilà l'émission Salut les Terriens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Bonsoir vous occupez le fauteuil du JT
de 13h de TF1 depuis le 22 février 1988
ça vous épate
[Musique]
4 ans et 3 mois et voilà alors tous les
jours un téléspectateur sur 2 x 7
million de Français vous regarde et nous
aussi on vous regarde
bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est
absolument super bonne fête superbe
super image était superbe aussi les
endroit superbe des villages superbe
super vendre aussi tu as dit coccinelle
c'est joli planter ses fleurs de jolies
fleurs du notre très jolie fait de jolis
bateaux une jolie promenade d'une
formidable opération qu'une formidable
performance en forme toujours aussi
magique je voulais dire une très belle
région encore une belle région et des
villages ça autrement images belles
histoires en tout cas les images
magnifiques ces paysages magnifiques un
endroit merveilleux d'un endroit
merveilleux je vous l'avais de la beauté
des régions on s'en lasse pas et c'est
phénoménal
j'avais vu ce petit montage de ce type
c'est vrai que c'est bien fait c'est
plein d'humour et c'est sympa alors
Jean-Pierre pour préparer cette émission
j'ai regardé votre journal toute la
semaine et j'ai eu envie de voter
Pompidou c'est normal ça veut pas dire
ça
non j'ai réussi à en bois dans le
journal
aujourd'hui
critiquer Libération se moque en disant
ce gîte et en sabots Crocs te révérend
les belles régions les mettez oublié et
la Maouche ardéchoise cuisiner par
grand-maman c'est la première
destination touristique mais
[Applaudissements]
ça ne me pose pas de problème
dans le journal télévisé
il a jamais dit ça
[Applaudissements]
bon ben alors
moi j'essaie de faire mon métier je
crois que c'est un journal orienter un
journal c'est le journal on raconte la
vie des gens antenne télé avec les
préoccupations les difficultés les
crises les le chômage le pouvoir d'achat
on en parle bien plus que dans d'autres
édition plus institutionnels dans notre
chaîne vous êtes très très con
heureusement Michel Houellebecq vous a
rendu hommage incroyable dans la carte
et le territoire et vous à donner
l'absolution a quelques sorties dit le
trait de génie de Pernaut a été de
comprendre qu'après les années fric et
frime le public avait soif d'écologie
d'authenticité de vraies valeurs il
parle de vous en disant une personne à
qui tu es visionnaire je n'ai pas
rencontré depuis de
l'actualité immédiate rapide violente
insensé et accomplissant chaque jour
cette tâche messianique
consistant à guider le téléspectateur
terrorisée et stressé vers les régions
idyllique d'une campagne préserver
est-ce que vous aviez imaginer un jour
célébrer dans le plus grand écrivain
français jamais vous parler de
votre
et une pièce de théâtre qui
se joue
au théâtre du Gymnase
à être premier ministre qui se fait
filmer
lors d'une soirée déguisée avec des
copains on va faire le tour du net et
détruire
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui
ça marche bien c'est pour ça qu'on l'a
prolongé au théâtre le public et c'est
l'essentiel et une première pour moi de
voir un texte on a écrit avec Nathalie
et Jean-Claude sur scène c'est c'est
c'est formidable d'entendre voir les
comédiens s'accaparer un texte
autobiographique parce qu'en 2005 à
participer à l'émission de TF1
avec un autre
c'est tout
et puis et puis voilà
[Applaudissements]
alors vous dit effectivement en épousant
et Miss France j'ai commencé intéressé
les paparazzis les vendeurs de papier
normal tranquille avant avant j'étais
tranquille dans ma campagne j'allais
jardiner non puis après le fait le
succès de journal bon mais c'est tout on
doit on doit vivre avec un minimum
doigt dans la confiture une séance photo
et puis après il y en a d'autres
[Applaudissements]
en tous les cas c'est une belle réussite
pour le fils de la pharmacienne
Dequevauviller quand même
mon père et
ma mère étaient dans un petit village et
puis une seule seconde à la télé
[Applaudissements]
Nathalie en fait draguer à Miss France
où se trouve écoute à côté il
y a eu un c'est Madame de Fontenay
organisé le truc à côté de vous il y a
une fille qui s'était assise à la plage
et
[Applaudissements]
voilà et voilà
et
puis voilà
[Musique]
tout de suite à ça a été sinon c'est
normal
j'ai découvert voilà c'est cette jeune
femme que je sais pas qui
m'a raconté c'est sa vie son cancer sans
parler librement du cancer avec
quelqu'un et puis quand je vois la pêche
qu'elle a aujourd'hui mais faut en
parler du cancer
2 jours plus tard vous envoyer un
bouquet de roses blanches à son adresse
comment
gérer son téléphone quand même
et puis j'ai demandé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour discuter avec nous actualités de la
semaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours en compagnie de
Jean-Pierre Pernaut
Mathieu Pégase
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes directeur
général de la banque d'affaires Lazare
France propriétaire de l'île de Madère
Les Incorruptibles
collectionneur du journal Le Monde et du
site Huffington Post publier révolution
chez Plon on va en parler alors
commençant par la banque Lazard c'est
une banque d'affaires la grosse
différence avec une banque normal c'est
quoi c'est quand les gens vont faire des
retrait de points qu'une droite
sécante c'est pas droite donc
nous ne faisons pas de financement nous
ne faisons pas d'opération financière la
seule chose que nous faisons ou que nous
donnons on ne prête pas on donne ce sont
nos conseils et donc nous conseillons
soit des entreprises pour leur
développement en France ou à l'étranger
soit des gouvernements et c'est dans le
cadre de cette activité de conseil que
moi par exemple je me suis occupé de
l'Argentine après ça te dit en 2001 ou
plus récemment de la Grèce parce qu'elle
était laisser seul face à elle m'aime
alors vous êtes la vedette des
fusions-acquisitions c'est vrai que
Nicolas Sarkozy vous a consulté avant de
fusion
alors vous êtes né le 25 mai 1968 à
Clichy dans les Hauts-de-Seine dans une
famille où tout le monde est dans
l'édition de la Presse votre grand-père
a créé la collection le masque qui a
amené Agatha Christie votre père à
diriger vers la Manche Libre votre oncle
a été directeur de l'Express votre frère
et cofondateur du magazine People public
qui était le père de Zohra Dati
est
dans le
groupe de rock
désespoir ouais sans grand succès les
mercenaires de
incroyable que j'ai reçu je
me souviens la première fois
et je suis resté après les 2 minutes de
la chanson KO debout
et ce jour-là j'ai compris quelque chose
on peut venir de nulle part et tu
sais que
quoi
et puis
ouais les clashs c'est un groupe engagé
par exemple
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis subjugué
la banque c'est pour moi l'instrument et
moyen de la Liberté
à New York
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'étais jeune conseiller technique j'ai
beaucoup appris à ses côtés
professionnellement
[Rires]
qui me connaît pas s'exposer au retour
des ministres vous partez dans le privé
donc c'est Lazaroo la gagner beaucoup
d'argent et vous dit j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance dans la vie j'ai gagner de
l'argent je veux rendre à la société ce
qu'elle m'a donné c'est pas mal ouais
alors d'abord qui m'amène à la banque
c'est quand même l'utilité sociale et le
général j'ai eu la chance vraiment et
l'honneur de conseiller l'Argentine
quand elle était en pleine faillite j'ai
eu la chance et l'honneur de conseiller
les Grecs là il y a sur les 2 dernières
années et effectivement j'ai eu beaucoup
de chance je suis arrivé la grâce au
fond des rencontres de livres de musique
on en a parlé daughter vous n'êtes pas
schizo
est le
nom de ce côté-là j'essaie quand même de
tout ça tout ça se rejoigne
dans le monde
poste vous aider la gauche pourquoi vous
avez perdu un pari parce que j'y crois
vraiment Président de la République
moi je ne fais pas partie de son équipe
de campagne
à faire quelque chose d'utile
non mais c'est bien moi je suis fière si
vous voulez d'avoir des idées sont pas
nécessairement celle de mes intérêts les
intérêts supposa c'est
moi qui vient de ce petit village qui
étaient confronté à la question de
l'avenir je dis dans ce livre la
question fondamentale qui nous est posé
c'est celle de notre avenir à nous tous
nous européens qui a vont dominer le
monde pendant des siècles 16e siècle qui
avons connu des décennies croissance
heureuse mais nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans une impasse totale en fait vous
dites la crise n'est pas seulement
financière contre nous raconte toute la
journée c'est une crise globale une
crise de civilisation c'est une crise en
fait du modèle européen merci à mon sens
beaucoup plus qu'une crier c'est un
changement de nom de l'Europe ne crois
plus en plus des années depuis des
décennies on se l'ai caché si vous
voulez en accumulant de la dette et on a
découvert soudainement par l'absence de
croissance que le roi était nul et on se
retrouver avec des tonnes et demi il
faut maintenant
dans quel département optimisation
fiscale qui aide ses clients à payer
moins d'impôts non non non nous nous
sommes de bons conseils
c'est
très bien
parce que je considère que
il faut
un pays complètement musée ils
ont parlé du vieux
vieux vieux vieux et ça c'est
pas bon
[Rires]
tu m'as dit tout à l'heure
[Applaudissements]
gros sujet dans le 13h de TF1
je suis un fervent supporter de François
Hollande là c'est fini pourquoi vous
gagner plus d'un million d'euros par an
donc
je reste un ami
avec les cheveux gris
non mais
[Musique]
énormément
de
travail
et puis il
faut surtout pas parler des quartiers
populaires parce que il faut
alors qu'il y a
plus de chômage que sur le territoire
national que vous avez 40 pourcents de
chômage chez les jeunes je pense qu'il y
a urgence
aujourd'hui
si vous voulez on ne veut pas prendre
des risques dans ce sens-là il va
falloir s'occuper profondément de ces
jeunes ils sont délaissés qui sont
désespérés et qui a un moment on se
retrouve dans le giron de Jean
d'extrémistes qui promettent autre chose
mais pourquoi les jeunes de la campagne
ils sont pas dans le même cas votre avis
qui sont tout aussi des WC feuille de
plan campagne plan ils ont pas d'emploi
non plus et les gens par jour des
quartiers les quartiers il y a il y a
toute la France qui a parfois des
problèmes sauf que dans les quartiers
populaires vous avez quand même des gens
vous avez plus de chance de tomber sur
des des intégristes dans ces quartiers
la queue à la campagne et c'est ça toute
la différence et lorsque vous êtes
désespéré je peux vous assurer que ce
sont des gens qui arrive à avoir de
l'influence sur ces gamins là parce que
vous vous êtes perdus lorsque vous êtes
vous sentez délaissé par la République
et ben souvent le refuge dci se trouve
la
parler en ce qui concerne le Parti
socialiste de mépris et d'esprit
colonialiste quand même
oui parce que il y a un moment où
il y a une caste qu'il a
des amis énarques qui sont persuadé que
pour la science infuse surtout ils font
tout tout tout pour que les gens qui ne
sont pas issus du même sérail que je
n'accepte pas au fonction décisionnaire
donc et garde Toulon parfois même qu'on
vous leur apporter des projets ils vont
jusqu'à enlever la dénomination du
projet pour pour se réapproprier pour ne
pas que ça vienne des gens qui sont de
la base et moi ça me dérange
profondément colonialiste quand même
parce que quand on vous caresse dans le
dos on vous dit ah oui c'est très bien
ce que vous faites et tout ça
[Musique]
stabilité on ne veux plus que ça soit
les autres qui le fasse pour nous notre
génération stop
[Applaudissements]
quand vous êtes arrivés au PS et ils ont
commencé à planter les sacs à main les
portables c'est déjà passé
alors j'ai une question j'ai une
question idiote pour vous mais ça me
turlupine vous êtes originaire du Togo
c'est ça c'est un crocodile vous vous
feriez quoi
maintenant à l'actualité de la semaine
avec les hits de placo et c'est l'avocat
et Gilles William Goldnadel que nous
retrouverons sur ce plateau après le
magnéto
au début de la semaine on s'interrogeait
sur l'identité du joueur de Toulouse et
de Montauban avis ton père a un néonazi
à un djihadiste ou un déséquilibre et
c'est notre colère et notre indignation
il nous fallait un coupable
si l'assassin arrêtez tu es un
psychopathe comme Richard d'urnes qui a
tué 8 personnes à la mairie de Nanterre
en 2002 on aurait accuser la fatalité
éventuellement ça aurait relancer le
débat sur l'internement d'office des
personnes dangereuses en tout cas pas de
quoi changer le cours de la campagne
crime avec été commis par un commando de
skinhead néonazi
c'est le retour de la bête immonde
Marine Le Pen mais finalement le
coupable s'appelle Mohamed Merah c'est
un terroriste qui se revendique de
pouvoir parler d'autre chose que
le président de Sarkozy
dans tout ça il a pas le choix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'était les listes de Blacko mise
en images de Julien grave voilà Gilles
William Goldnadel Bonsoir vous êtes
avocat et CIC vous venez de publier le
vieil homme m'a dit aux éditions
Jean-Claude Gawsewitch bienvenue parmi
nous alors est-ce que la dernière
victime du tueur de Toulouse n'est pas
Hollande ça veut dire à qui va profiter
cette histoire je n'en sais rien du tout
parce que c'est ainsi dans une semaine
cette affaire-là sera totalement
derrière nous alors on peut bien sûr
gloser sur le fait que que Sarkozy va
être plus aller sur les sujets régaliens
sécuritaire tout sur la ligne Grassion 3
sujets qui sont évidemment totalement
dans le cadre et je comprends
parfaitement qui les utilisent à bonne
escient mais pour autant il y a aucune
certitude en tous les cas je n'ai aucune
certitude sur le sujet à Marine Le Pen
quand même parce qu'elle est sur le mode
je vous l'avais bien dit
ça pourrait effectivement sur le papier
profité
mais comme c'est un musulman ça va lui
profiter
de mettre les Français dans le vent
sur la piste
pendant 3 jours avant avant qu'on sache
qu'il s'agissait je me suis battu en
disant soyez prudent malheureusement
l'histoire est têtu depuis 30 ans que le
sang juif cool en France à chaque fois
on a essayé de mettre les gens dans le
vent avec l'extrême droite et à chaque
fois ça a été la piste moyen-orientale
ou islamistes qui était la bonne donc
quand j'ai vu SOS Racisme pour ne pas
les citer privilégier la tête de
l'extrême droite j'avoue que c'était une
manière un peu curieuse de partager le
deuil national
Jean-pierre vous pensez que ça va
profiter avec qui cette histoire sur le
plan politique je sais pas quelque part
je m'en fous pardonnez-moi mais ce qu'il
veut moi je pense surtout aux parents de
ces trois soldats dans de musulmans qui
a été assassiné 3e étais catholique je
pense aux aux aux familles juives de
cette école juive
qui attrape une petite fille par la tête
et qui lui met une balle à bout touchant
je pense pas qu'il puisse se référer de
quelques idéologique ce soit et je pense
pas que qui que ce soit plus le
récupérer c'est une tristesse immense
joie que je vois pas qui pourrait
bénéficier de ça ou pas en bénéficier
c'est dramatique ce qui s'est passé on a
vu la réaction de gouvernement sur les
mesures à prendre pour mieux surveiller
les les gens qui vont se former comme ça
en Afghanistan au Pakistan bon on va
voir après aux électeurs de voir qui est
suffisamment solide pour réagir à ce
genre de situation à l'avenir
est
républicain qui en profite je m'en fous
je veux dire que ça m'inspire je pensais
évidemment un drame épouvantable un acte
abject Mohamed Merah lieu a pu
l'habiller de considération
politique religieuse philosophique en
réalité c'est un acte démon et barbares
et ça montre que le premier des combats
c'est celui contre la barbarie il faut
impérativement s'il voulait se garder de
tout de surenchère populiste je veux
dire par là c'est qu'il faut pas
stigmatiser telle ou telle pratiques
religieuses le corps politique ou
philosophique en raison d'un acte de
quelqu'un qui était démonté rien
musulman rien et les musulmans de France
ont été les premiers à condamner est le
premier ministre Palestiniens à
condamner ce qu'il a fait là c'est autre
chose si on n'est pas du tout dans un
cadre politique personne ne peut de
toute façon au nom de l'islam parfois il
y a des gens qui ont pas réagi de façon
assez virulente lorsqu'il y a eu
certains événements mais cette fois-ci
je pense que tout le monde a pris
conscience que là il y a il y a un
niveau qui attend et comment on souligne
d'ailleurs il y a des musulmans aussi.
Été tué dans l'affaire et donc je pense
qu'il faut il faut dépasser la politique
politicienne pour une foire et donc ce
qu'on s'en servir de toute façon je
pense que ça fonctionnera pas
présenté
intégral comme un paumé ou comme un fou
c'est un peu court le djihadisme
l'islamisme n'as pas attendu
Mohamed Merah pour Séville en Israël on
a on a éclaté une petite fille à coup de
Pierre c'était un islamiste et on a
égorgé un bébé 3 mois pour les mêmes
raisons dont il ne faut quand même pas
considérer que c'est un acte isolé
Gilles il faut il faut qu'on fasse
attention quand même il faut pas rentrer
sur ce terrain-là moi j'ai dans ma tête
c'est images de 7 enfants palestiniens
avec son père qui était blotti contre
lui il y a il y a il y a une dizaine
d'années et qui se qui se fait buter
devant les caméras dans la logique
perverse dans dans dans dans laquelle
justement les djihadistes voudrais te
mettre un
jour un enfant
dans une école pour des enfants juifs
il faut faire attention parce que
juste de
tuer ce gamin
j'ai vu j'ai eu cette image
dans un début de commencement de
justification de la justifiable ok
bientôt alors
alors est-ce que
ça
va être comme avant
comme si rien ne s'était passé voilà moi
je ne pense pas parce que il est évident
que
si à la campagne de Sarkozy
est le peuple français de débattre sur
les questions de sécurité de
souveraineté nationale
il y aurait aucune raison qui qui a dit
ça non non c'est pas ça c'est un certain
nombre de d'utiliser fin l'utilisation
d'un certain nombre de termes de concept
qui je trouve relève de la
stigmatisation à nouveau sans lien avec
le drame à ce qui s'est produit j'ai
aimé je suis prêt en débattre je dis
juste que quand on l'oppose par exemple
systématiquement ceux qui travaillent à
ceux qui ne travaille pas en laissant
croire que ceux qui ne travaille pas au
fond ne choisit oui c'est quelque chose
qui me gêne c'est ce que j'appelle jouer
sur la peur janvier est-ce que la
campagne peux continuer comme avant ou
et son tour je pense que c'est événement
bien sûr on en parlera dans la campagne
comme vous le disiez il y a aucune
raison d'arrêter de parler des points de
sécurité d'immigration on continue à en
parler comme avant d'être avec un plus
de prudence de part et d'autre donc la
campagne je pense qu'il y a pas de souci
elle va elle va bien également reprendre
on va on va reparler bien évidemment de
l'emploi on va bien évidemment vous
parler de l'économie depuis que j'ai
tout ce qu'il a fait occuper les
Français et ça en fait partie aussi
je plais vraiment pour que qui que ce
soit ne se servent pas de de cet
événement pour quoi que ce soit on a
parlé de l'identité nationale qui était
au débat au départ le débat sur l'islam
et ensuite on a eu la burqa et ensuite
on a vu ouais il y a une succession de
choses qui font que la manière dont se
fait c'est pas débattre débattre au
contraire quand on arrive à parler en
général on dégonfle et conflits c'est
comme dans un couple hein c'est pas vrai
c'est terminé avec la viande halal
exactement donc voyez le problème c'est
qu'il peut y avoir lorsqu'on a certains
sujets et la manière dont les entame
alors
j'ai publié le vieil homme
et
une est devenu une icône
alors qu'il ne le mérite pas du tout
sur lesquels il a bâti la rédaction de
la déclaration de droit universel en 48
à 1 ans vous dit qu'il était pas
vraiment dans le coup ça a été vraiment
un passeport qui doit conférer un
magistère intellectuelle et morale
invraisemblable or il n'a jamais été le
coup rédacteur de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme de 48 c'est pour ça
que j'ai dévié ce livre à René Cassin
qui est qui en est le véritable
rédacteur lui qui me choque le plus en
fait c'est quand tu dis qu'la la
violence des Palestiniens et aussi
légitime que la violence des résistants
français pendant la guerre contre
l'occupant nazi en gros c'est ça ça
en
est
où
il s'indigner dans le monde c'est Gaza
d'accord on va conclure que c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de la
littérature éditions quand livre citron
[Musique]
on se rejoint après la pub avec le Lion
et notre amitié du samedi 20h ce soir
pour son livre une larme m'a sauvée
à tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours en compagnie de
Jean-Pierre Pernaut
Matthieu Pigasse
ce soir
être enterré vivant est l'une des pire
angoisse existentielle
c'est ce qu'elle fait et vous arrivez
Angel
dans le coma sur un lit d'hôpital vous
ressentiez et vous entendiez tout ce qui
se passait autour de vous mais tout le
monde vous croyez morte les médecins
envisagés même de vous débrancher et là
j'ai versé une larme une larme qui vous
a sauvé la vie
vous nous raconterez votre histoire à
20h en attendant j'accueille Stéphane
Guy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à vous Stéphane Guillon 2012
une revue de presse très facile à écrire
cette semaine grâce à une actualité
légère joyeuse et festive tuerie à
Toulouse accident d'autocar en Suisse
enfants fauchés sur une autoroute et
c'est quand même d'être drôle m'a
demandé canal+
me demander d'être drôle en pareilles
circonstances ce serait comme demander à
Mimi Mathy d'être championne de basket à
Gilbert Montagné de conduire une voiture
ou à Jean-Pierre Pernaut d'être de
gauche
alors on y va the show must go on
tremblement de terre au Mexique pas de
pertes humaines recenser ah c'est con ça
il y a pas une crèche qui a été écrasé
avec des tout-petits une maternité c'est
con c'est con mais autant faire une
semaine plein groupe et toutes les
difficultés et après on est tranquille
[Musique]
en Iran les footballeuses vont être
obligé de jouer vous allez je rappelle
quand hockey sur glace la burqa est
obligatoire depuis des années
c'est le moment de énervé
[Applaudissements]
de faire de la politique un jour encore
une mauvaise nouvelle c'est vraiment une
semaine de merde
Le Moulin de Claude François va devenir
un petit hôtel avec la reconstitution
fidèle de la chambre de Cloclo qui
serait bien aussi c'est de reconstituer
la salle de bain avec l'Afrique de
travers le client peut s'électrocuter
comme son idole
dans terre dans le jardin de la star
qu'on appelle la la pension complète
à quand un hôtel Mike Brant le client
arrive ses valises se defenestre une
formule très rentable qui permet de
louer la chambre plusieurs fois par jour
nouveau suicide à France Télécom après
la très belle remontée de la poste qui a
enregistré deux suicides en une seule
semaine
magnifique réaction de France Telecom
qui prend la tête au classement général
je pense que dans une semaine très noir
il faut alléger la presse ça permet aux
téléspectateurs de un
petit peu
alors qu'on assassine en Syrie la femme
de Bachar el-Assad Asma fait du shopping
sur internet meubles de luxe bijoux et
chaussures Louboutin Louboutin c'est une
connerie connerie payer une fortune des
chaussures sous prétexte qu'elles ont
une semelle rouge autant acheter des
chaussures normales et marcher dans la
rue avec tout le temps que fait couler
son mari les semelles dasma bon c'est un
tu es très vite
c'est la fête est-ce que
notre cerveau
de neurones que prévu 86 milliards au
lieu de 100 à mon avis il y a des gens
qui font chuter la moyenne mondiale
après la tuerie de Toulouse France 2
s'est fendu d'un communiqué pour se
réjouir du record d'audience du journal
d'Elise Lucet une semaine près il avait
l'autocar Suisse le même jour et là
c'était champagne à france 2
c'est toujours le 11 septembre qui est
en tête des audiences à france 2 c'est
pour grouper les catastrophes il faut
arriver quand même
Thierry quel fait quel fait
et on termine on termine avec un coup de
chapeau au magazine Gala qui cette
semaine a choisi d'afficher le bonheur
des enfants de Johnny et Laeticia leur
vie rêvée dans son star titre le
magazine manucure glacier et shopping à
Los Angeles il n'y a pas que des drames
il y a aussi du bonheur merci à gala de
le rappeler la semaine prochaine c'est
la fin
[Applaudissements]
travail si la semaine prochaine et d'ici
là sur Canal+. Fr on passe maintenant à
notre invité du samedi 20h
Angellier dire bonsoir à Strasbourg le
25 mai 1952 petite dernière d'une
famille d'agriculteurs
cinq frères et soeur vous dit nous
sommes les enfants de la terre en France
heureuse
le travail aux études très tôt vous
prenez le chemin de l'usine pour
commencer à gagner votre vie
et vers l'âge de 16 ans vous rencontrer
un garçon un petit peu plus âgée que
vous appellerai
et quand vous montrer sa photo à une
voyante elle vous prêt dit que vous
épouserait un homme en uniforme
effectivement vous épouser Ré en 1970 il
devient policier
et vous aurez une fille quelques mois
plus tard s'appelle Cathy voilà vous
travaillez dans une usine de tricotage
pendant plus de 20 ans et quand elle
ferme je travaille dans une usine qui
fabrique des chariots pour les
supermarchés les aéroports les hôpitaux
et vous c'est vous qui mettait les
meilleurs
du vélo
et
rien d'inquiétant
ou de la nana c'est d'un seul coup une
supporter plus l'acidité de l'ananas
alors le 13 juillet 2009 en arrivant
dans le parking de l'usine vous
travaillez vous ressentez un picotement
au bout des doigts
cure comprimé examen ponction lombaire
ils comprennent rien à ce qui se passe
au temps de traiter en pire vous passez
rapidement un raidissement puis a une
espèce de paralysie et autour de vous tu
deviens vaporeux cotonneux comme un
brouillard
plus doucement que j'arrivais plus à
manger ni à boire à ce moment-là et
bientôt vous commencez avoir des
difficultés pour respirer quoi
sans trop m'en rendre compte
en commun thérapeutique pendant 1 ou 2
jours et là quand vous reprenez
conscience tout est noir autour de vous
passer
à côté de vous
être humain
en fait c'est le respirateur artificiel
qui maintient en vie et qui
est
vous vous sentez en forme
ne le savais pas encore que vous avez
repris conscience alors que votre corps
est toujours inerte et là en fait vous
êtes emprisonné dans votre propre corps
comme
ils ont les yeux ouverts ou fermés
j'arrive même pas à ouvrir faire rien
alors les gens qui vient de vous voir
très consciemment en fait
ça me fait du bien
crier mais aucun son ne sort de votre
bouche
il faut vraiment que je renvoie un signe
mais vous n'avez pas le moyen de le
faire en fait je peux rien faire
la visite d'une voisine qui vous dit
Angèle même dans le coma tu es belle
CAF
en fait de tout ça
n'arrêtait plus
alors pour s'assurer que vous êtes bien
mort parce que tout le monde vous vous
crois morte on vous fait le fameux test
du téton parce qu'en fait le test du
téton n'importe qui qui a encore un peu
de vie saute en l'air.
et moi j'ai pas bougé rien même pas une
paupière donc ça ce que ça voulait dire
j'ai entendu une femme qui disait
parce que toute façon elle va clamser
elle a entendu ça
qu'il a dit
pour vous à ce moment-là c'est de vous
dire comme j'ai demandé à être incinéré
après ma mort je n'essaierai pas de la
télé
ça me soulage et autres angoisses vous
aviez dit avec Marie que si vous
m'auriez vous vouliez de donner vos
organes à d'autres gens et là je sais
pas que quelqu'un rentre dans la chambre
vous pensez qu'on a vous préférez le
cœur ou le froid
entendre parler de vos obsèques
inconcevable au bout de 4 jours que que
c'était la fin le temps passe et un jour
c'est votre anniversaire de mariage
et cathy sont avec vous et votre fille
vous dit ne t'en fais pas ma petite
maman je prends soin de papa et là vous
êtes énervé par l'émotion
enfin sorti
le premier qui a fonctionné
c'est du gel un petit doigt
mais très peu mais bon
et un peu plus tard les yeux les yeux se
sont ouverts
aujourd'hui
presque une année
maladie s'appelle la maladie de
Bickerstaff
de dégradation soudaine de la myéline tu
as une réponse disproportionnée du
système immunitaire
suite à une infection
heureusement se régénère naturellement
dans votre mail il est revenu c'est
une substance qui ce que je veux dire
c'est que la cocaïne ça
pendant votre aucun signe
alors que vous étiez
et
comme ça
aujourd'hui
savent pas ils connaissent pas trop non
plus cette maladie parce que moi j'étais
la 15e dans le monde cette maladie
est
le titre de votre livre donc c'est
publié aux éditions les arènes
on y est pas
c'est bon hein croyable histoire
moi je trouve très belle la façon dont
vous en parler je trouve ça très beau
avec dignité et que la leçon vous en
tirez l'espoir l'ouverture sur les
autres voilà je pense à très émouvant je
vais revenir sur le PC au fond moi en
vous écoutant
never surrender c'est-à-dire de lâcher
il y en a toujours un espoir c'est vrai
pour tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à Matignon au Théâtre du Gymnase Mathieu
pour révolution chez blanc merci
dans 13h et 20h et
voilà
pour le
[Musique]
rendez-vous samedi prochain
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu